the major
reason for success at the beginning is
to have an idea the most important word
in our business is desire i am
very competitive
so it's like in tennis i always want to
win
need motivation watch at top 10 with
believe
my top nation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best bernard arno
and my take on his top 10 rules for
success enjoy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one have an idea our
culture is based mainly on creativity
and in the startup
the major
reason for success at the beginning is
to have an id
a creative id an innovative id that is
really putting
the company
with an advance
to everybody else
it should be to be successful a game
changer rule number two create an
impeccable brand when i was managing
family business which was in a different
sector
i happened to
enter in contact with
a group in france that was
having problems
business problems
and in this group there was christian
dior
and
i was interested
by business
and i wanted to
turn around this group
and build
on which i think was at the time
the best asset and the best i said
was christian euro and and
i was interested in christian dior
for a long time because the first time
you know you are very young but the
first time i was in
new york
it's in
71.
and i remember the first time i arrived
at
kennedy airport
i took a cab
and at the time the president of the us
was
richard nixon
by the way
they were devaluating
the dollar during the summer
where i was there i bought dollars and
my dollars went down
but
i arrived at the airport
and
i started to talk
to the cab driver and he loved france
and he was interested in politics so i
asked him
and he did not like mixer so he was
talking
about that he said
you love franco what do you know in
france do you know the french president
it was mr pompidou at the time
nobody here remembers but
he said no i don't know the french
president but i know cristiano
and
immediately
he stuck me and showed that
the name of christian dior
is one of the if not the most known all
over the world
in many countries when i go to china
when i go everywhere it's
the name which is the most well known so
as far back as 71
[Applause]
i understood the power of a name it's
not enough but
i think it's one reason also
when by chance i was in contact with the
real company
i think it's when i had the idea of
doing this rule number three be prepared
i am interested in business so in
business
i think we are in a very strange
period
for several years money is almost
costing zero
if not a negative interest which means
that some companies
has nvmh for instance when we borrow
money we are paid to borrow money i
think it's dangerous two
you have a lot of money in the market
three
the prices of assets like stock prices
are extremely high
so i am very optimistic for the world
for the long term but i see as
unavoidable that the crisis happen
within the next few years i cannot tell
you exactly when but bubble are
inevitably building up now and at one
point they will explode
it's the first time i have seen that
since i am in business and since i am in
business i have seen crises almost every
10 years
it very soon will be over the last
period of 10 years without anyone so
rule number four execute well almost as
important as the idea at the beginning
is the execution and the fact that
[Music]
building on the id
must be
really
very professional very efficient
and that also makes a difference i have
seen a lot of startups
with
very interesting ideas
but with also some
other competitors
almost with the same ideas but only one
or two of them are successful it's
because the execution of
their business plan
so it's key for the long-term success
of a
startup
to be able to execute well
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special free training to help
you do it the science says it can take
up to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit of
self-belief so what i'm gonna do is
email you every day for 254 days a link
to an unlisted video that will shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below if you have a great
product lots of people will buy it and
then the company will be successful you
really have to believe the internet's
going to be mainstream a lot of people
are going to get out there and use it
your number one job is to become more of
yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself rule number five welcome new
ideas i think our companies are very
involved in the tech world
because take us more and more important
on the way we do business for instance
if you take
one of our companies sephora separa is
doing
a lot on e-commerce in the u.s for
instance it's the number one site
selling beauty products in the u.s
so we are always in touch with new ideas
with newcomers with startupers and we
try to
find the best for instance in lv image
here in viva tech we have had 800
applications for
startups we chose 30 of them and among
the 30 we will
choose
one two or three that will be announced
tomorrow that i think
we think will be the most promising for
the future rule number six create
quality what do you think the definition
of luxury is
first of all
i don't like very much the word luxury
because you have something attached to
it which means show off
which means something
of
non-significance something
futile something that is
useless
and
i think a better definition is
combination of
quality and creativity it's how i define
what we do
obviously these products because of the
very high quality
they have
because of the high level of innovation
they are expensive
but
the reality
is really
behind
the appearance behind the price
it's
the quality
and
the innovation that people are looking
for
so for me it's a definition and
in the group we are really concentrated
on this
how can we create
the most
innovative products
and the creators
or the scientists that work with us in
the many laboratories we have
they have complete freedom
to
express new ideas
and
after that we have to transform them
in
reality
all over the all over the world rule
number seven be fair with the consumer
when the currency is going down
we have the possibility of increasing
gradually prices like we did recently in
the us five percent because our products
are so in demand that we can do it but
obviously we are very fair with the
consumer when the currency goes back up
which can happen which happened in the
past we do the opposite so we can
decrease prices also if for instance the
dollar comes back up we can also play it
the other way to be fair with our
consumers rule number eight start small
for us it's uh i would say way of life
because
almost all of our brands
were started if you
take points on christian dior it was
started
from scratch
in 1947
and we tried to keep the same spirit
which is spirit of being close
to the founder and close to
movement and new ideas
and
also i must say that the startup the
startup we
see today
their goal is not to stay startup
forever they want to grow
the goal of a startup is becoming a
large company if you take
for instance facebook or
microsoft
they were startup at one point now they
are quite big
and we try to help
the startups that we chose today to
become
a big success and i think it's a goal of
every startup
this being said it's not always easy
rule number nine create desire you have
students in marketing
but
i often meet
students in marketing
and
in spite of the group being number one
with the students in france
in desirability to work
in the group
i always tell them
we don't do marketing
because marketing
is against
what a company like us should do
because marketing what is marketing
marketing
is to
analyze
what the customer wants
and then try to follow
what the customer is looking for
and
test
what you
create
following these trends
and try to to do it
we do
completely differently
we create new products
and
sometimes it fails but
when it's successful
the customers follow
so the marketing is not for us
part of the product creation
so marketing is after
the marketing
is
when
we have these products
how with these products
which people
want
maximize the desire
because our business you ask a question
about luxury luxury
for for me is
how can you create desire
the most important word
in our business is desire how to create
desire and
when you have the product
then you have to create
good environments
in the shops and you have to present it
well you have to do
well
good films if it's a perfume
good
advertisement
either in the magazine or in the
internet if it's uh if it's a product
that the way i see and we see in my
group
the way to the way to
put product
in contact
with
the
the consumers and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is be competitive i am never bored
it's what i have in mind when i think of
myself young it's fun
and i am
very competitive
so it's like in tennis i always want to
win
and that's fun now i've got some special
bonus clips that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you just watch a
video and you get motivated the sign
says you have a 35 chance of actually
following through that's not good enough
believe nation we need to take some
action but when you watch a video you
get motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video your number jumps to 95
percent change of you actually following
through on the plan you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week leave it
down in the comments below so i can
celebrate you we are investing for a
long time
we are
buying investing in startups of any kind
fashion startup digital startup i think
the best example i can give you is a
sephora you know when we invested in
sephora in the 90s it was a starter
and today it's maybe the largest
retailer of beauty products in the world
and we have started also very early
beginning of 2000
a digital operation which is based in
san francisco where we have i think one
of the best digital team in the world
and uh it's extremely successful for
instance we're number one seller on the
digital
on the web
of beauty products in the u.s far above
amazon
you know so so
we know how to manage startups and how
to make them grow because remember
startups the goal of the startup is not
to stay started
the goal of the startup is to grow and
to become if possible a large company
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there